[Music]
I'm optimistic that we can create an
awesome future with technology as long
as you win the race between the growing
power of the tech and the growing wisdom
with which we manage the tech and this
is actually getting harder because of
nerdy technical developments in the AI
field it used to be when we wrote state
of the art AI like for example IBM is
the blue computer who defeated Garry
Kasparov in chess a couple decades ago
that all the intelligence was basically
programmed in by humans you knew how to
play chess and then the computer won the
game just because they could think
faster and remember more but we
understood this software well
understanding what what your AI system
does is one of those pieces of wisdom
you have to have to be able to really
trust it the reason we have so many
problems today with systems getting
hacked or crashing because of bugs is
exactly because we didn't understand the
systems as well as we should have and
now what's happening is fascinating
today's biggest AI breakthroughs are of
a completely different kind where rather
than the intelligence being largely
programmed in and easy to understand
code you put in almost nothing except
the little learning rule by which the
simulated network of neurons can take a
lot of data and figure out how to get
stuff done and this deep learning
suddenly becomes able to do things often
even better than the programmers were
able to do you can train a machine to
play computer games with almost no
hard-coded stuff at all you don't tell
it what a game is what is what the
things are on the screen or that there
even is such a thing as a screen you
just feed in a bunch of data about the
colors of the pixels and tell it hey go
ahead and maximize that number in the
upper left corner and then gradually you
come back that it's playing some game
but much better than I could the
challenge with this even though it's
very powerful is it's very much a black
box now where yeah it does all that
great stuff and we don't understand how
so suppose I get sentenced to 10 years
in prison by a robo judge in the future
and I ask why and I'm told I was trained
or
seven terabytes of data and this is the
decision it's not that satisfying for me
right or suppose the machine that's in
charge of our electric power grid
suddenly malfunctions and someone says
well we have no idea why we trained it
on a lot of data and it worked and that
doesn't instill the kind of trust that
we want to put into systems you know
when you get the blue screen of death
when you're in Windows machine crashes
or the spinning wheel of doom because
your market crashes annoying it's
probably this main emotion we have right
but annoying isn't the emotion I would
have if it's myself - flying airplane
that crashes or the software controlling
the nuclear arsenal of the US or
something like that and as I gets more
and more out into the world we
absolutely need to transform today's
hackable and buggy AI systems into AI
systems that we can really trust
[Music]